It's halftime.
Both teams are in their locker room,...
...discussing what they can do to win this game in the second half.
It's halftime in America, too.
People are out of work and they're hurting.
And they are all wondering what they gonna do to make a comeback.
And we're all scared, because this isn't a game.
The people of Detroit know a little something about this.
They almost lost everything.
But we all pulled together, now Motor City is fighting again.
I've seen a lot of tough eras, a lot of downturns in my life.
And times when we didn't understand each other.
It seems that we've lost our heart at times.
The fog of division, discord and blame made it hard to see what lies ahead.
But after those trials, we all rallied around what was right and acted as one.
Because that's what we do.
We find a way through tough times, and if we can't find a way, then we'll make one.
All that matters now is what's ahead.
How do we come from behind?
How do we come together?
And, how do we win?
Detroit is showing us it can be done.
And, what's true about them is true about all of us.
This country can't be knocked out in one punch.
We get right back up again and when we do,...
...the world is gonna hear the roar of our engines.
Yeah, it's halftime America.
And, our second half is about to begin.